Вітаю! Я Леонід Горобець.
Сьогодні проведу урок на
тему "Покриви тіла тварин"
Першочерговим призначенням
покривів є захист організму
від факторів навколишнього середовища.
У найпростішому варіанті покриви
представлені
простою епітеліальною тканиною.
Вона може бути багатошарова, одношарова,
залежно якої саме тварини це стосується.
Під епітелієм або над ним можуть
знаходитись додаткові шари.
В більшості випадків під епітелієм
знаходяться шари сполучної тканини.
В деяких організмів м’язи
зростаються із покривами,
утворюючи єдину структуру
– шкірно-м’язовий мішок
Окрім того, додаткові шари
можуть бути поверх епітелію.
Наприклад, кутикула червів або
хітиновий панцир членистоногих тощо.
На відміну від, власне, епітелію
та сполучної тканини, покриви,
що знаходяться поверх епітелію,
не містять кліткової структури.
Познайомимось із прикладами
покривів тварин різних типів.
Перший тип – кишковопорожнинні або жалкі.
В цих тварин покриви представлені
простою епітеліальною тканиною.
Проте в ній трапляються
деякі спеціалізовані клітини.
Самі відомі з них – це скоротливі клітини.
В скоротливих клітинах знаходиться
жалка нитка, яка допомагає
кишковопорожнинним в полюванні та захисті.
Окрім того, в деяких кишковопорожнинних
клітинний покрив виділяє утвори,
які формують твердий скелет навколо тіла.
Такими є корали.
В червоподібних істот, такі як: круглі
черви, кільчасті черви, плоскі черви,
покриви представлені
шкірно-м’язовим мішком.
Він допомагає рухатися цим тваринам.
В представників Круглі черви
дуже низька здатність до регенерації.
Найменше механічне пошкодження
може бути смертельно
небезпечним для цих тварин.
Тому їх тіло вкрите
поверх щільною кутикулою,
яка захищає їх від механічних пошкоджень.
Окрім того, щільна кутикула
допомагає тим круглим червам,
які ведуть паразитичний спосіб життя,
захищатися від
внутрішнього вмісту господаря.
Таких як, наприклад, шлунковий сік.
В представників Кільчасті черви,
кутикула також наявна,
але вона значно тонша.
Це зумовлено тим, що кільчасті черви
мають нормальну здатність до регенерації.
Механічні пошкодження не
являються небезпечними для них,
як для круглих червів.
Переважна більшість кільчастих
червів живе в твердому середовищі.
Такому як ґрунт, мул, пісок тощо.
Пересуватися в ньому значно
важче, ніж на повітрі чи у воді.
Тому в кільчастих червів добре
розвинений шкірно-м’язовий мішок.
Зверніть увагу, наскільки
потужні м’язи в кільчастих червів.
І порівняйте їх із відносно
невеликими м’язами
шкірно-м’язового мішка круглих червів.
Окрім того, в покривах кільчастих
червів можуть бути чутливі волоски.
Вони можуть бути невеликими
як, наприклад, в дощового черва,
представника класу Малощетинкові.
А можуть бути досить розвинуті, як у
представників класу Багатощетинкові.
Якщо покласти дощового
черв’яка на листок паперу,
то можна почути легкий шурхіт.
Цей шурхіт зумовлений тим,
що волоски чіпляються об папір.
Окрім того, покриви дощових
черв’яків постійно виділяють слиз,
який захищає їх від
пошкоджень під час пересування.
Цей процес безперервний
впродовж всього життя тварини.
І якщо його покласти, наприклад,
в скляну банку, де немає потреби
захищатися, слиз не припиняє виділятися.
З часом на стінках банки
можна побачити сліди слизу
Характерною ознакою типу Членистоногі
– є наявність хітинового панцира
поверх покривів, який являється
зовнішнім скелетом цих тварин.
Він виконує ряд важливих
функцій. В першу чергу – захисну.
Хітиновий панцир дає
досить надійний захист.
Не кожна комахоїдна пташка
здатна впоратись із великим жуком.
А із хітиновим панциром омара
навіть людині важко впоратись
без додаткових інструментів.
Окрім того, завдяки
наявності зовнішнього скелету,
комахи та інші членистоногі
вирішують питання пересування
в гонитві за здобиччю
або під час втечі від хижака.
В представників класу Ракоподібні
хітиновий панцир поверх не
має захисної воскової кутикули,
оскільки ці тварини мешкають
переважно у водному середовищі.
Втім, деякі ракоподібні
мешкають на суходолі.
Такі як, наприклад, мокриця
або краб пальмовий злодій.
Однак і в цьому випадку у них немає
додаткової кутикули, яка захищала б їх.
Тому всі ракоподібні змушені
триматися вологих місць.
Що ж до Павукоподібних та Комах,
то в них поверх хітинового покриву
наявна воскова кутикула,
яка захищає від випаровування.
Тому вони успішно опанували суходіл.
Крила комах також являються
певною мірою похідною шкіри.
Вони розвиваються як складка шкіри,
в яку заходять судини з гемолімфою
і забезпечують рух комах.
Тобто на відміну від хребетних тварин,
в яких крила являються
видозміненою кінцівкою
із скелетом, м’язами тощо.
Крила комах – це, власне,
розрості складки шкіри.
В Молюсках в покривах розвивається
особлива складка,
вона називається мантія.
Її можна побачити, наприклад,
навіть у супермаркеті.
Філе кальмарів є не що
інше, як мантією цих тварин.
Сушене кільце кальмарів є мантією
молюсків, нарізаною на шматочки.
Мантія виконує ряд важливих функцій.
Насамперед, це складка, яка
огортає тіло тварини, захищаючи його.
Також вона виділяє спеціальну речовину,
якою формується мушля молюсків.
Вона посилює захист тварини.
Деякі молюски відмовилися від
мушлі, проте мантія в них збереглася.
Ще одне призначення мантії
– захищати зябра цих тварин.
В однієї групи молюсків, зокрема
в легеневих черевоногих молюсків,
мантія видозмінилася і
перетворилася в легені.
Завдяки цій трансформації,
черевоногі є єдиною групою молюсків,
які змогли опанувати суходіл.
Цікаво, що поява дорогоцінних перлин
теж, до певної міри,
завдячує клітинам мантії.
Коли якась дрібна піщинка чи інший
подразник потрапляє під складку мантії,
то подразнює тварину. Захищаючись,
молюск починає виділяти перламутр,
який огортає піщинку,
згладжуючи її гострі кути.
З роками шари перламутру потовщуються.
Таким чином утворюється перлина.
Більшість перлин не мають
такої цінності з точки зору людини.
Вони можуть бути сіруватого
кольору, буруватого.
Можуть бути неправильної форми тощо.
Проте часом між перлинами
трапляються справжні коштовності
ніжного рожевого відтінку,
сніжно-білі, блакитного відтінку,
ідеальної круглої форми тощо.
Втім, не варто забувати, що з
точки зору двостулкового молюску,
перлини це не розкіш, а спосіб
уберегтися від подразника.
Що ж до Хордових тварин, то в них
покриви представлені
двома основними шарами.
Поверх знаходиться
епітеліальна тканина – епідерміс.
Під епідермісом знаходиться
сполучна тканина, яка називається шкіра.
В шкірі хордових тварин часто
розвиваються різні похідні шкіри.
Такі як луска, пір’я, шерсть.
Познайомимось з похідними
шкіри на прикладі різних тварин.
І почнемо з риб.
Поширена точка зору, що
луска рибам потрібна для того,
щоб захищати їх від механічних
подразників. Інколи це так.
В деяких риб луска потужна і
забезпечує досить непоганий захист.
Проте першочергове
призначення луски інакше.
Подумайте, навіщо луска величезній
акулі? Від кого їй захищатися?
Разом з тим, її тіло вкрите численними
лусочками.
Річ у тім, що основне призначення луски
– це збільшувати
гідродинамічні властивості риб.
На цьому малюнку зображена
риба в якої нібито немає луски.
Коли риба пливе, довкола її тіла
утворюються додаткові завихрення,
які ускладнюють рух тварини.
Коли ж наявна луска, то кожна луска
розбиває завихрення води
на менші потоки. І, таким чином,
зустрічний опір води слабшає,
риба починає швидше плисти.
Цю хитрість риб підмітили люди. І
використали в матеріалі sharkskin.
Він використовується для
виготовлення плавальних костюмів.
Sharkskin є тканиною, в якій чисельні
маленькі виступи імітують луску акул.
Спрацьовує той самий процес.
Під час плавання маленькі виступи
розбивають течію,
полегшуючи пересування у воді.
Матеріал sharkskin цілком дозволений
для плавальних костюмів
в особистому використанні.
Проте він настільки ефективний, що
для професійного спорту заборонений.
Поглянемо на будову
луски хрящових риб ближче.
Їх луска дивовижним
чином нагадує будову зуба.
Зверху вона вкрита шаром твердої речовини.
Дуже подібної за хімічним
складом до емалі зубів.
Під цим шаром знаходиться шар
дентину. Такий самий як в наших зубах.
Вчені припускають, що зуби з’явились
в древніх хордових як похідні шкіри.
Складки шкіри загорнулись на щелепи,
а луска на них з часом
перетворилася на зуби.
В кісткових риб луска інакша.
За своєю будовою вони являють
пластинки із кісткової речовини.
Такої самої як побудовані наші кістки.
Тільки луски звичайно
значно тонші, ніж кістка.
Вони утворюються в шкірі.
Шар, який має меншу здатність
до регенерації ніж епідерміс.
Тому коли риба втрачає луску,
вона вдруге не відновлюється.
Луска росте разом із рибою. Оскільки
в рості організму є періоди
інтенсивного росту, а є періоди спокою,
то вони відображаються і в рості луски.
Утворюються річні кільця.
Порахувавши кількість річних
кілець, можемо дізнатися який вік риби.
Окрім того, в шкірі риби є чисельні
залози. Вони одноклітинні і виділяють слиз.
Основне призначення слизу –
зменшувати тертя риби об воду.
Цим самим збільшуючи її гідродинамічність.
Окрім того, слиз виконує
бактерицидну функцію.
Він захищає організм риб від
різних патогенних мікроорганізмів.
Шкіра амфібій виконує важливу функцію.
Вона сприяє газообміну цих тварин.
В амфібій фауни України через шкіру
відбувається від 15 до 40% газообміну.
В деяких амфібій через шкіру
відбувається 100% газообміну.
Такими є, наприклад, дуже поширена
в світі група – безлегеневі саламандри.
Або один із видів жаб
з острова Калімантан.
Для того щоб здійснювалось дихання,
шкіра повинна бути постійно вологою.
Якщо шкіра висохне, то амфібія загине.
Зволоження шкіри досягається за
рахунок діяльності численних залоз.
Які, на відміну від залоз риб,
являються багатоклітинними.
Вони виділяють слиз,
що зволожує шкіру жаби.
Також слиз виконує і бактерицидну функцію.
Оскільки постійно волога, нічим
особливо не захищена шкіра жаби
є ідеальним середовищем для розвитку
різноманітних бактерій, грибків тощо.
Єдиним способом захиститися
від патогенних організмів є слиз
із бактерицидними властивостями.
Окрім того, в деяких амфібій слиз
використовується для захисту від хижаків.
Він містить у своєму
складі отруйні речовини.
У типового представника
фауни України – ропухи,
шкірні залози помітні у вигляді
чисельних бугорків по шкірі.
А особливо добре помітні позаду очей.
Ці бугорки чимось нагадують бородавки.
Тому існує хибна думка про
те, якщо торкнутися ропухи,
то по тілу розвинуться бородавки.
Це не так. Поява бородавок немає ніякого
відношення до контакту із ропухами.
Єдиний хто може постраждати
від контакту із амфібією
– це, власне, сама ропуха.
В середині цих залоз,
дійсно, наявна отрута.
Вона досить неприємна в
тому випадку, якщо з’їсти жабу.
Це захищає ропух від
різноманітних хижаків.
Отже, єдиним способом постраждати
від отрути ропухи, це з’їсти її сирою.
Що, я сподіваюсь, вам в голову не прийде.
В рептилій шкіра інакша.
Вона повністю суха,
на відміну від амфібії.
Оскільки це тварини, які ведуть,
першочергово, наземний спосіб життя.
Деякі рептилії вторинно
перейшли до водного способу життя
(морські черепахи,
крокодили, деякі ящірки тощо).
Проте основне середовище
рептилій – це суходіл.
Захищаючись від випаровування, а також
для захисту від механічних пошкоджень,
в епітелії розвивається лусковий покрив.
Він інакший, ніж лусковий покрив риб.
Луска рептилії відрізняється
від луски риб. У випадку з рибами,
луска – це просто кісткові
пластинки, занурені в шар шкіри.
Вони не відновлюються. В рептилії
луска – це виділення епітелію.
Шар, який має високу
здатність до регенерації.
Рептилія без проблем регулярно скидає
із себе лусковий покрив і формує заново.
Окрім того,
в шкірі деяких рептилій можуть розвиватися
захисні структури – кісткові пластинки.
Наприклад, кісткові
пластинки в шкірі крокодилів.
Проте найбільш відомі
такі утворення у черепах.
Панцир у черепах є комплексом,
який утворюється за рахунок шкірних
пластинок, які утворюються у власній шкірі.
А також внаслідок зростання із ребрами
та деякими іншими кістками скелету.
Що ж до залоз, то в тілі рептилій
майже відсутні шкірні залози.
Особливістю покривів
птахів є наявність пір’я.
Цю ознаку вони успадкували
ще від своїх предків – динозаврів.
Оскільки динозаври не літали,
то очевидно, що першочерговим призначенням
пір’я є не політ, а якась інша функція.
Припускають, що це могла
бути, наприклад, термоізоляція.
А також динозаври могли
використовувати пір’я
для приваблення шлюбного партнера.
Або для маскування, оскільки
не всі динозаври були велетенські.
Деякі були крихітками,
розміром не більші за синичку.
Що ж до пір’я птахів, то воно
також багатофункціональне.
Пір’я наявне в усіх птахів, навіть у
тих, які не літають (пінгвіни, страуси).
Пір’я допомагає птахам
зберігати тепло навколо тіла.
Допомагає маскуватися,
приваблювати партнера,
Літати або навіть видавати звуки.
Характерний звук під
час зльоту зграї голубів
виникає за рахунок особливої
будови пір’я цих птахів.
Завдання такого пір’я
– створювати сигнал до польоту,
який зрозумілий всім іншим голубам.
Коли злітає один голуб,
утворюється такий звук і всі інші
птахи також на нього реагують.
Деякі птахи пристосувалися
використовувати звуки,
які створюються пір’ям, як шлюбну пісню.
Наприклад, у фауні України такий птах,
як баранець або інша його назва – бекас.
Самці цього виду під час шлюбного сезону
злітають в небо і стрімко опускаються донизу.
Поблизу хвоста в них особливі пір’їни.
Повітря, коли проходить повз їх,
видає особливий звук, який
чимось нагадує «бекання» баранця.
Саме тому українська назва
цього птаха – бекас або баранець.
Що ж до шкірних залоз, то
їх в тілі птахів майже немає.
Лише одна єдина залоза
– куприкова залоза знаходиться на
верхній частині птаха, поблизу хвоста.
Виділення цієї залози
мають жироподібну природу.
Птах змащує ним своє оперення.
Цим самим захищає його
від механічних подразнень,
а також збільшуючи
водовідштовхуючі властивості.
Найкраще куприкова
залоза розвинена в тих птахів,
які мешкають поблизу
водойм або є водоплавними.
Однак є винятки. Наприклад,
такі птахи, як пелікани, баклани.
Попри те, що вони є водоплавними птахами,
у них погано розвинена куприкова залоза.
Як наслідок – вони змушені
часто після плавання
сушити своє пір’я. Розставивши крила вбік.
Також в тілі птаха
зберігся лусковий покрив.
Його можна помітити на
пальцях нижньої кінцівки.
Окрім цього, луска вкриває дзьоб птаха.
В даному випадку всі луски зростаються
між собою в єдиний роговий чохол.
В деяких птахів цей чохол може утворювати
невеличкі виступи, схожі на зуби.
Проте нагадую, що
справжніх зубів у птахів немає.
Ссавцям притаманний волосяний покрив.
Він наявний майже в усіх ссавців,
окрім деяких видів дельфінів.
Першопочатковою будовою
волосяного покриву є шерсть.
Проте вона може видозмінюватися
і набувати інших форм.
Наприклад, волосся людей,
голки їжаків, дикобразів тощо.
Роговий чохол на рогах
різних тварин або сам ріг.
Наприклад, ріг носорога є нічим іншим,
як чисельними зрослими волосинами.
Існує уявлення, що ріг носорога
наділений чудодійними,
цілющими властивостями.
Тому його ціна досить висока,
більше ніж 1000 доларів за 1 кг рогу.
Його продають і використовують в
різних псевдомедичних процедурах.
Однак за хімічним складом ріг носорога
не відрізняється від наших нігтів чи волосся.
Тобто його лікувальні властивості приблизно
ті ж самі як жування нігтів чи волосся.
Цього робити, звісно, не варто.
А тим більше, не варто платити таку
величезну суму за недієву речовину.
Кігті, нігті, копита – також є
видозміненим волосяним покривом.
Однак інколи у ссавців
зберігається і лусковий покрив.
Зокрема луска помітна
на хвості у гризунів.
Або в таких тварин як
броненосці, панголіни тощо.
В деяких ссавців волосся
видозмінилося у вібриси
– тоненькі довгі волоски,
які знаходяться на мордочці
у гризунів, котів та
багатьох інших ссавців.
Вібриси виконують чутливу функцію.
До основи таких волосків підходять нерви,
завдяки чому вібриси можуть
функціонувати як додаткові органи дотику.
Це важливо для тварин, які ведуть
нічний спосіб життя (коти, пацюки).
В шкірі ссавців, на відміну від птахів та
рептилій, наявні численні шкірні залози.
Найбільш відомі із них – потові залози.
Досить добре потові
залози розвинені у людей.
Оскільки наш вид еволюційно
розвинувся як хижак, який заганяє здобич.
Потрібно постійно бігти за здобиччю.
В результаті організм перегрівається.
Для вирішення питання терморегуляції
в нас функціонують потові залози.
В інших ссавців потових
залоз може бути значно менше.
Одні із видозмін потових
залоз є молочні залози.
Вони наявні в усіх ссавців.
І виділення із молочних залоз
допомагає їм вигодовувати малят.
Також в покривах ссавців
наявні сальні залози.
Їх протоки виділяються у волосяну сумку.
Жироподібний секрет
сальних залоз змащує волосся,
цим самим захищаючи його
від механічних подразників.
Також збільшуючи
водовідштовхуючі властивості волосся.
Окрім того, у багатьох ссавців, однак –
не у людей, на тілі наявні пахучі залози.
Виділення цих залоз
використовується для мічення території,
приваблення шлюбного партнера,
передача сигналів (сигнал тривоги).
Отже шкіра, яка першопочатково
виконувала функцію захисту
від
навколишнього середовища,
в подальшому набула багатьох
інших додаткових функцій.
Лунає дзвоник. До побачення.